[Music]
welcome to the review of the MAC at the
studio I mean welcome to the review of
the Mac Studio
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so this is the computer I
personally got really excited about when
they announced it because we've built a
video Studio here and this computer is
literally called the Mac Studio so the
entire purpose is to be the ideal
computer that is small and powerful
enough to be in a studio environment and
had all these example studios in the
Apple event from music studios to Design
Studios to specifically video Studios
and so they made a little Cube the size
of Two and a Half Mac minis with a bunch
of i o some new Cooling and an M1 Max or
an M1 Ultra chip inside specifically to
live in these Studio environments and so
now
I've got one here in our studio so I've
been throwing all types of tasks and
projects and accessories at this thing
including this new studio display which
I also plan on making a separate review
about because it's pretty weird make
sure you get subscribed for that and I
actually have two but I've mostly been
putting my time into testing this M1
Ultra version because it's the newest
biggest baddest chip so I call this the
2x machine basically everything about
this machine is doubled now I'm going to
be referring to the M1 Max chip a lot
during this review so if you haven't
already seen the MacBook Pro review with
the M1 Max chip in it that's going to be
very helpful I'll leave that link below
the like button this one basically
doubles all the things so physically
speaking it's basically like two Mac
minis stacked on top of each other
melted into one thick Mac Mini three C's
and this is incredibly small for the
amount of power it puts out it can sit
on any desk alongside speakers or a
monitor or whatever you set it up with
also it is a total coincidence but I set
mine up on this desk I got from Blue Dot
which already has a bunch of these
perforated holes that remind me of the
mac and it fits absolutely perfectly
underneath the shelf so that a monitor
can sit on top of the Shelf without
actually sitting on top of the computer
anyway this is the back of the computer
which has a full Suite of i o even more
ports than the Mac Mini there are four
Thunderbolt 4 ports a 10 gigabit
Ethernet port the power plug two usb-a
ports an HDMI 2.0 Port not 2.1 again for
some reason and a headphone jack that
can support higher impedance headphones
just like the MacBook Pro now it's not
kicking out world-class audio by any
means it's not going to replace my
universal audio DAC but it is convenient
to have kind of the same way HDMI is
convenient although I'm kind of
surprised this one doesn't do HDMI 2.1 I
get it on the laptop that's just so you
can plug in a random monitor on the go
but this is going to sit at your desk
and it would be nice to have high
refresh rate but at the same time the
Ford Thunderbolt ports will support up
to four Pro display xdrs which are all
6K so I guess he got back on for you but
then at the front Halo look look at that
front i o which is nice because this is
going to sit on a desk not under it so
up front here that's going to be two
USBC ports if you get the base M1 Max
version but those graduate to two
Thunderbolt 4 ports if you get the M1
Ultra version because there's literally
more buses available and then an SD card
slot because every Studio I know has
tons of SD cards lying around somewhere
so it turns out if I wanted to replace
my Mac Pro today that is enough I O for
me to actually do that so I've got two
Thunderbolt displays and then one
Thunderbolt raid array and the DAC the
universal audio DAC is also Thunderbolt
so all together plus a couple card
readers I'd be set now Apple did use the
word modularity in their presentation
I don't know if that word means what
they think it means I mean maybe if
they're just trying to say because it's
not connected to a display and you can
choose your own unlike the iMac that's
what they're considering modular if not
then I have no idea what they're talking
about because this thing is absolutely
not modular at all all of the parts
inside are soldered in there is no
upgrading of the Ram or the GPU or any
parts of this thing ever for the entire
lifetime of the machine I'm not even
sure there's any reasonable way to
actually open up and get into the Mac
Studio so yeah I can't give you modular
on this one apple but also this level of
vertical integration is basically
required to get a computer to be this
small and this efficient like I've seen
some small PCS before this one is Tiny
also the power supply is built in so
there's no wall wart it's all just in
this little box and also fun fact Apple
did send both the M1 Max and M1 Ultra
versions here to the studio to test and
the M1 Ultra version is in fact notice
possibly heavier than the max it's two
whole pounds heavier it turns out that's
because the heatsink they used in the
ultra version is made of copper instead
of the aluminum one they put in the M1
Max it's much more dense it's heavier
that's pretty serious but I think that's
my cue to talk about the inside of this
machine a little bit more because that's
where the 2x theme starts up again so
you remember the event the M1 Ultra is
literally two M1 Maxes basically fused
together with a high enough bandwidth
between them to behave like one huge
mega chip which is awesome because that
means two times the CPU cores two times
the GPU cores two times the memory
bandwidth and two times the total memory
so in applications I can take advantage
of this stuff well this should be twice
the machine now Apple did the whole
thing they always do with graphs and you
know you can never really take these
completely at face value I did do some
synthetic benchmarks though and for a
lot of them it does behave like twice
the computer it it absolutely blew the
doors off every other Mac ever made
especially including the iMac Pro and it
even flirts with the 28 core cheese
grater Mac Pro that I've been using so
in geekbench it ties the highest single
core score I've ever seen and then it
drops a multi-core score literally
double the M1 Max MacBook Pro and yes
that also makes it more powerful in the
CPU Department than any other Mac ever
including 28 core Mac Pro then in the
cinebench test which I think is a little
more realistic ran it for 10 minutes and
it gave me around 24 000 which again is
about double the M1 Max and is right in
line between a 16 core thread Ripper and
a high thread count Xeon chip like the
Mac Pro basically the CPU benchmarks are
killer until could never but then we got
to talk about GPU stuff it gets a little
more interesting so you might remember
Apple's graphs were comparing at one
point the ultra to an RTX 3090 they kept
saying it'll have the same performance
as an RTX 3090 but at 200 Watts less
power and that's very impressive but it
turns out the graph should continue a
little something like this because the
RTX 3090 will happily continue to draw
way more power up to 400 watts of power
it's one of the power hungriest cards
ever so shout out to heimgartenberg at
The Verge for this chart inspiration so
it turns out it doesn't beat the RTX
3090 at anything that you would buy an
RTX 3090 for which I didn't really
expect it to because that card is almost
exclusively for gaming like you buy that
to play games and you would never buy
this to play games but hey double the
cores still do double the work so on
geekbench's metal Benchmark which
measures GPU performance with things
like image processing I got nearly
double the score of the M1 Max MacBook
Pro cracking a hundred thousand which is
around what a Radeon Pro Vega 2 Duo in
my Mac Pro scores but the Mac Pro has
four of them now synthetic benchmarks
are cool and everything but you don't
buy a computer like this to just try to
get the highest benchmark scores you buy
a new computer to see if that new power
can translate to real world performance
and real world workflows and so
basically what I've noticed most is the
more well-optimized the app the closer
you get to those 2x performance numbers
nothing really typically hits exactly 2x
but the M1 Ultra does feel faster a bit
sometimes than the M1 Max I mean in
everyday performance just zipping around
the Mac yeah this thing slaps it makes
me really wish I had a high refresh rate
monitor here that plays nicely with the
Mac because that would actually feel way
more responsive like the MacBook Pro
with its Pro motion screen but you know
5000 plus megabytes per second read
write speeds from the drive things open
instantly it's great and then in my own
workflow you might know by now I'm a
Final Cut Pro editor here it did give me
more Headroom and it did perform better
than the M1 Max MacBook Pro but again it
didn't quite beat the Mac Pro I'm
currently using basically it's gotten to
the point where I can drop fresh 8K raw
files on the timeline in better quality
playback mode immediately hit play and
start tweaking color and messing with
raw settings and it plays back perfectly
at 30 frames without hesitation minimal
lag when I hit the play button I love it
it's when you start adding layers of
objects and plugins and animations and
trackers on top that things do start to
slow down and I can still bring it to
its knees with enough layers of moving
objects like I had I had six at the
beginning of the iPad Air review but
then when I got to the export at the end
of the video it took the Mac Studio 7
minutes and 30 seconds to export my
iPhone SE review which is pretty
impressive but interestingly this same
project took 6 minutes and five seconds
to export from the Mac Pro so it's still
more powerful it just has more raw
horsepower but of course not everybody's
using Apple's own apps like I do with
Final Cut there are plenty of Premiere
Studios there are lots of DaVinci
Resolve Studios hell even in this studio
we've got people using heavy Photoshop
and after effects stuff for thumbnails
and Motion Graphics so I am happy to
report that adobe has been working
through their Suite the newest After
Effects beta is dramatically faster on
Apple silicon so that's awesome and I'm
gonna link an article from Scott Simmons
where he went through a bunch of tests
between Premiere and resolve comparing
the M1 Ultra with the M1 Max and you can
see a consistent performance improvement
with all the heavier stuff like adding
warp stabilizer rendering a heavy clip
Etc the only thing I did find where the
M1 Ultra didn't beat the M1 Max was
interestingly just a straight up prores
video export sorry for the tons of video
comparisons but hey it's a video studio
so this was one area where it did smoke
the Mac Pro because the new prores the
media engines in these Apple silicon
products are great the M1 Ultra has
literally double the media engine of the
M1 Max so I thought it would be twice as
fast
while they both beat the Mac Pro it was
roughly the same time to export a single
prores clip but generally yeah it might
not have matched the Mac Pro at every
single little thing I threw at it but
yeah if you're not a video person I'll
let you find The Benchmark that applies
best to your workflow but generally with
the stuff I threw at it M1 Ultra heavily
outperformed M1 Max and it did it all
very quietly with very little heat in
this tiny little box that just sits
inconspicuously on your desk I mean this
computer makes it so obvious why they
were eager to ditch Intel also let me
give a shout out to the sustainability
element here too so they use recycled
materials inside these computers that's
cool and then even the packaging I don't
think people understand how hard this is
the packaging for these computers is
absolutely incredible fully recyclable
lots of padding moving parts and then
with a literal floating cardboard
platform in the middle for shock
absorption it's wild I would not be
surprised if just this box added like 50
bucks to the price of the computer just
to engineer such a ridiculous package
but as far as real world impact the
biggest chunk of that will come from the
efficiency of these chips of course
Apple says that it'll use over a
thousand kilowatt hours less energy per
year than an average PC desktop that's
good for your electricity bill but
that's also good for the environment but
at the end of the day look this is just
a tool right just like the app or
program you're using already is just a
tool and so I think people look for the
The Benchmark that will prove that this
machine will make them better at what
they do it can't do that like just
because it's fast if you're bad at
editing and you get this machine you'll
still be bad at editing but just faster
but I am really happy to see new
machines like this still coming out that
do make big leaps in performance and
capability sort of raises the ceiling
for what you can do now all that being
said
the Apple silicon Mac Pro is still
coming
and I say that not even like as a
warning to most people but just to
remind myself because honestly most
workflows are covered with the Mac
Studio like if I today if I'm a YouTuber
and I'm just editing 4K or 8K even
prores all the time
this will be able to handle it but if
you're doing large 3D modeling projects
or tons of tracking and layers and after
effects or even in audio projects lots
of plugins and video stuff if you're
really pushing the limits of your
machine the Mac Pro platform still does
offer the most horsepower so I mean it
shouldn't it shouldn't be surprising
that the current 40 pound 28 core you
know 768 gig of RAM Mac Pro manages to
slightly outperform this little tiny box
here but when we do get the new Apple
silicon Mac Pro I do expect performance
to double this one up again which is
crazy to say out loud but for everyone
else
this thing is overkill and I love that
that's the narrative around this
computer like do you really need that
much power probably not but hey at least
it's five thousand dollars of Overkill
versus
25 000 of Overkill so
it's a bargain
either way that's been it thanks for
watching catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]